one hundred and sixty one point eight
billion euros is the total amount of the
draft budget the European Parliament has
set for funding any policies in 2017 the
any piece want to give Europe the means
it needs to meet its challenges
avoidance is Catan viadon can women in
house are mobile is yet OD for huntin
and Merc dish carton complete notes to
report Jackie lusatia me report a
service a budget significative aa
complete legacy will continue our
bandwidth FS he's not [ __ ] necessity
necessity Donatella croissants in a vase
dismal necessitated should nearly
predictability a victim Barabbas deeply
Eden embargo is now necessitated has a
message positive erogenous European not
to mention the migration and security
crisis rocking the Union but the
European Parliament does not decide the
EU budget alone the 28 member states
also have their say and for them the
coffers are empty and the MEP should
revise their expectations down by 5.4
billion euros
the council is acting as if the world
never changed it wants to cut next
year's budget without much of a
strategic consideration of our
priorities and this simply does not make
sense especially now when money is
tighter than ever before the European
Parliament's draft budget paves the way
for what promised to be stormy
negotiations with the member states an
agreement should be reached by the 17th
of November 2016